turn this um what's on this in this
field here done this is sweet potatoes
that we had just planted okay we planted
solve them a week ago and then the ones
that are being irrigated now we planted
yesterday okay and it's very important
that you don't get rain after your
planting too if you don't have
irrigation it's it makes it real
difficult for the weather the plants get
a established after your clowns
you got your tractor hooked up to a pump
it's hooked up to a water pump that runs
out up on a PTO okay power take-off
power take-off okay and it it produces
about a hundred and ten gallons a lot of
a minute
you can use that for takeoff for any
number of things right
most anything with applications at the
track
if it requires a PPO
adapted to
and that thing actually moves is that
correct you've got it on our cable and
it yeah it went is itself across the
field that's why they call it a water
that's a water winch okay they drag the
hose behind it and we hook it to a tree
and it winches itself across the field
nice got three different views on it and
depending upon how dry it is Oh as far
as the speed goes I like the speed go so
that's how you regulate how much water
you put down as by how fast it it
winches across right it's got one two
and three and if I put it in the fastest
Gill I can put out half an inch of a non
before you get any moisture so these are
these are no these are red potatoes what
kind of these are red potatoes can I get
you to hold those up again there you go
you say these are potatoes that this is
what potatoes look like when they need a
little rain yeah see these actually if
we if we if we did not get any more rain
yeah or like let's say this crop didn't
get water anytime this week mm-hmm and
we didn't get irrigation on it then what
what happened is these small potatoes
would size up as long as vines are still
green okay that's how they would size up
but that's not what you want do you want
two potatoes to size up with moisture
rather than from the vine Oh in other
words it would be taking the moisture
moisture out of the vine there it would
be that's and then when the vine is dead
the potatoes are done going okay I mean
there's at least at least a good month's
gross here
yeah these potatoes could size this
potato being not much bigger than a
marble right would could size up to the
size of your fist by the time it's to be
harvested so that rain is really
critical right now very critical so some
people go to Las Vegas to gamble and you
choose to fire my guess
that's exactly right
well so here's the potatoes that we get
at the farmers market nice if we don't
get any rain if this storm misses us
tomorrow night I'll have to set up your
Legation over here and that's going to
take me a day over to one well at this
point every day is critical sure
brilliant so maybe maybe mother nature
will be kind to us tomorrow night and
one hope so
how many feet long are these that
Greathouse is 128 feet long 128 feet
long and you've got all tomatoes in here
all tomatoes in this box that you've got
in here what is that that box down there
is a beehive there's a beehive
it's got bumble bees in it okay and
that's how we pollinate the tomatoes
okay one
flowers flowers like this
when they open up the bee pollinates
maybe with a little luck we might see
some bees pollinating okay and then
again we may not it depends on what the
humidity is in here right in the only
pollinate when the humidity is just
right oh is that right but sometimes
you'll still see them flying around
pollinating it it looks like the more
ripe tomatoes are at the bottom is that
at the bottom and having ripe and then
you just
this would be picking this cluster next
week the next week if you take off of
this cluster this week will be taken off
of this cluster
so they're open from the bottom and then
they keep on growing they grow up they
grow up to these schools that are
okay and if it will
you taken
let them down like that and move them to
the right that's what they call leaning
and lowering I've never heard of that
and then the vines eventually at the end
of season you'll have a big long column
of vines you can see this they've been a
roller to fight a few times already so
the findings are all leaning this way
and you've already picked the tomatoes
off the bottom
they're already been picked off the
bottom okay like some several weeks back
okay so you give them a little bit of
slack with the reel when the wheel the
right just like a domino effect and when
they reach the end
and what are they planted in their
planet in media called pearl a pearl
white pearl a okay it's a white media
it comes out of volcanoes
and then it felt like a vermiculite or
exactly and there's in the same family
is that it takes the place of soil okay
then how does it get watered they take
it out of volcanoes and then they pop it
just like popcorn hello and then it
turns into this I didn't realize that it
makes a good media base for soil I did
not realize that
really holds water well and how does it
get watered two of these feed to each
tomato plant has its own feed too so
they have plenty of water and it's all
put out
okay
that's what they call cat face it can't
facing cat facing and it's due to cold
temperatures doing pollination
right after pollination ok so that's
that tomato was falling way back in
February very small tomato and that's
why it turned out that way
can't facing interesting so this is the
strawberry this is how we grow the
strawberries the Grauman's stack is like
this this is everbearing variety and
this another held up with pipes and then
you've got what this black pipe is what
water this is a feed tube and then
they're just put on stack is that we
evolve so when you're picking you can
just spin this like you can oh very
convenient like a miniature carousel you
might soon and here's this one that
being a burbank variety we'll see what
the summer brings i'm sure sure nice and
this is the same way we grow out greens
for the winter time
oh is it right is that right winter
farmers market Oh in stackers like this
ok
this is probably this is probably
equivalent to maybe several acres of
greens outside sure because of the way
we grow this is the vertical stacking
exactly perfect and the same with the
strawberry operation sure that little
half acre of stackers is probably
equivalent to like five six acres of
strawberries that's amazing and the
tomatoes the same thing Wow
same thing well would be equivalent to
well that particular house that tomatoes
are by the equivalent to about fifty
acres of tomatoes
Wow
if you try one
well we all enjoy your produce at the
farmers market and we certainly
appreciate you taking the time today to
show us around oh I was a pleasure was
all mine
okay thanks nothing